and brian clark county leaders sharing
what it plans when may 1st rolls around
the proposal really doesn't show many
changes for the immediate future for
instance
restaurants and bars will continue to
run at 50 percent occupancy indoors
but there's no limit for outdoor dining
gyms and retail stores will also be held
to 50 percent
and any large gatherings for events will
need to still need approval in advance
with the news that restrictions could
begin to gradually loosen over the next
month or so
local businesses are ecstatic madison
kimbrough spoke with one of the owner of
two restaurants in the southwest valley
tonight
madison continues our team coverage with
more on their excited reaction
madison yes andy hooper and several
other restaurant goers have been waiting
for this day for a long time but that
doesn't mean we didn't hear from those
who think it's too soon take a listen
with governor sisilak's announcement of
having everything reopened by june 1st
local restaurant owner andy hooper feels
like he can finally breathe again
big huge sigh relief i mean you know for
us we've been
looking forward to the day that we could
get something definite
when it came to capacity restrictions
the state of nevada will hand over the
control of mitigation measures to local
counties on may 1st
which means we could see clark county
fully open back up in a couple weeks
some people we spoke to feel it's too
soon while others are ready
i think people are jumping the gun a
little bit
there's still a lot of people out there
who have
chosen not to get vaccinated things can
still happen
really exciting that these restaurants
especially these local small restaurants
are getting to
reopen fill in their tables this
industry needs it for sure while hooper
can't wait to get more people back into
his restaurants
he says he still plans on following
social distancing guidelines even when
the mandate is lifted
our employees will still be wearing
masks we'll still be doing the
sanitation protocols that we've been
doing since the beginning
and we're going to try to adhere to that
social distancing mandate as long as we
can
[Music]
and the clark county commission will
vote on its plan for the next phase of
reopening
one week from today reporting live
madison kimbrough 8 news now